we talked about all kinds of Life we've
talked about all kinds of embodied Minds
what do you think is the meaning of it
all
what's the meaning
of all the biological eyes we've been
talking about here on Earth why are we
here
I don't know that that's a that that's a
well-posed question other than the
existential question you posed before is
that question hanging out with the
question of what is consciousness and
their uh Edward Retreat somewhere not
sure because sipping pina coladas and
because they're Ambiguously defined
maybe I'm I'm not sure that any of these
things really ride on the the
correctness of our scientific
understanding but I mean just just for
an example right
um I've I've always found I've always
found it weird that uh people get really
worked up uh to find out realities about
their their bodies for for example right
you've seen them uh ex machina right and
so so there's this great scene where
he's cutting his hand to find out he's
you know he's full of [ __ ] now to me
right if if I open up and I find out and
I find a bunch of cogs my conclusion is
not oh crap I must not have true
cognition that sucks my conclusion is
wow cogs can have true cognition great
so right so so it seems to me I guess I
guess I'm with Descartes on this one
then whatever whatever the truth uh ends
up being of of how is what is
consciousness how it can be conscious
none of that is going to alter
um my primary experience which is this
is what it is and if and if a bunch of
molecular networks can do it fantastic
if it turns out that um there's a
there's a non-corporeal you know Soul uh
great we could you know we'll study that
whatever but but the fundamental
um existential aspect of it is you know
if somebody if somebody told me uh today
that uh yeah yeah you were created
yesterday and all your memories are you
know sort of uh fake you know kind of
like um like like boltzmann brains right
and the human you know human skepticism
and all that uh yeah okay well so so but
but here I am now so so let's experience
is Primal so it like that's the that's
the thing that matters so the the back
story doesn't matter the explanation I
think so from a first person per second
now from a third person like
scientifically it's all very interesting
from a third person perspective I could
say wow that's that's amazing that that
this happens and how does it happen and
whatever but from a first person
perspective I could care less like I
just it just what I've what I learned
from any of these scientific facts is
okay well I guess then that's that then
I guess that's what is sufficient to to
give me my uh you know amazing first
person perspective well I think if you
dig deeper and deeper and get a
get surprising answers to why the hell
we're here
it might give you some guidance on how
to live
maybe maybe I don't know um that would
be nice on the one hand you might be
right because on the one hand if I don't
know what else could possibly give you
that guidance right so so you would
think that it would have to be that or
you would it would have to be science
because there isn't anything else so so
that's so maybe on the other hand
I am really not sure how you go from any
you know what they call from an is to an
ought right for manufactual description
of what's going on this this goes back
to the natural right just because
somebody says oh man that's completely
not natural it's never happened on Earth
before I I'm not you know impressed by
that whatsoever I think I think whatever
has or hasn't happened we are now in a
position to do better if we can right
well this also good because you said
there's science and there's nothing else
there it's it's really tricky
to know
how to intellectually deal with the
thing that science doesn't currently
understand
right so like
the thing is if you believe that science
solves everything
you can too easily in your mind think
our current understanding like we've
solved everything right right like it
jumps really quickly to not science as a
mechanism as a as a process
but more like the size of today like you
could just look at human history and
throughout human history just physicists
and everybody would claim we've solved
everything sure sure like there's a few
small things to figure out and just we
basically solved everything uh where in
reality I think asking like what is the
meaning of life
is uh resetting the palette
yeah of like
we might be tiny and confused and don't
have anything figured out it's almost
going to be hilarious a few centuries
from now when they look back at how dumb
we were yeah 100 agree so so when I say
uh science and nothing else I certainly
don't mean the science of today because
I think overall I think we are we know
very little I think most of the things
that we're sure of now are going to be
as you said are going to look hilarious
down the line
um so I think we're just at the
beginning of a lot of really important
things
when I say nothing but science I also
include the kind of first person what I
call science that you do so these so the
interesting thing about um I think about
Consciousness and studying Consciousness
and things like that in the first person
is unlike doing science in the third
person where you as the scientists are
minimally Changed by it maybe not at all
so when I do an experiment I'm still me
there's the experiment whatever I've
done I've learned something so that's a
small change but but overall that's it
in order to really study Consciousness
you will you are part of the experiment
you will be altered by that experiment
right whatever whatever it is that
you're doing whether it's you know some
sort of contemplative practice or
uh or or some sort of uh you know
psychoactive but you know whatever uh
you are now you are now your own
experiment and you are right and so so I
can I I fold that in I think that's
that's part of it I think that exploring
um our own mind and our own
Consciousness is very important I think
much of it is not captured by what
currently is third person science for
sure but ultimately I include all of
that in science
with a capital s in terms of like a um
uh a rational investigation of both
first and third person aspects of our
world
we are our own experiment as beautifully
put and uh when when two systems get to
interact with each other that's the kind
of experiment so I'm deeply on you would
uh do this experiment with me today
thanks so much I'm a huge fan of your
work likewise thank you for doing
everything you're doing
um I can't wait to see the kind of
incredible things you build so thank you
for talking I really appreciate being
here thank you